this is complete completely random calm
day at the Burke's what are we making my
other mic broke and this is this is what
we're going to use it's pretty cool to
hear everything by the way I up at at
you guys who comment about dr. brick
berg being so serious and I got a the
fruit loop this look looking at me which
what's she talking about
using a spherical okay oh and by the way
this is Charlie he was little shrunk was
getting a little big and so we decided
to put them in the dryer going to try
those good okay so this is a really
fascinating recipe these are actually
cauliflower reps because we're doing the
cruciferous recipes right yeah totally
so I really doubted this recipe I made
it and I'll be darned it actually makes
a completely foldable holds together
wrap that you can awesome make a
sandwich with or have a taco or anything
it's I didn't think it was possible I
was doubting it and I was wrong
this actually is a great little wrap I
even made a little sammich you want to
try it little sandwich yeah I want to
try it and I'll see this is
really gonna be a big hit you're like
especially for people that like red
unbelievable cauliflower whoever thinks
up who would have thunk it hmm that's
awesome mm-hmm
I'm really surprised but it was very
very easy cauliflower is one of these
things that just sort of morphs it's
kind of like tofu you know you can take
some flavors and it's this great
consistency and yeah clearly it's
another way to get consumed cruciferous
we're trying to get everyone to consume
more so right so not only can you
consume more cruciferous but you have a
bread replacement basically if you like
to have a sandwich or taco shell I think
or I mean you could just get created
they don't know right I am so impressed
I mean we have barely started to
experiment with these maybe you'll see I
don't know maybe we can do like crepes
with whipped cream and chocolate or
something I always go right to the
dessert menu right maybe but um with
eggs or you know stick an omelet in
there give your kids a little crappie
what do you think what are you doing
char go mmm
Toby likes it all right let's let's go
right into the show you how how to how
to part how to part yeah Roger that
[Music]
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video